en dépit de certains quartiers
privilégiés nancy ne peut véritablement
se prétendre ville verte après un début
de siècle ou arbres et pelouse faisait
bon ménage avec l'habitat il fallut en
effet se résoudre à renier peu à peu sur
la verdure pour agrandir les artères de
circulation pour augmenter le potentiel
de logements restaient encore les grands
parcs comme celui de la pépinière
véritable poumon d'oxygène de la ville
comme les parcs olry blondeau ou sainte
marie peu à peu cependant derrière les
airs de végétation est particulièrement
centre-ville se développer l'espace
béton larchitecture rue des lices au
service de l'habitat mais pas toujours
du cadre de vie
une conception qu'il devenait urgent de
modifier et nous penserons une politique
de développement de l'habitat doit être
accompagnée par une [ __ ] vert car il
faut essayer de vivre agréablement dans
une ville les espaces verts et participe
pour beaucoup alors il n'y a pas du tout
antagonisme je crois complémentarité et
en tout cas c'est ce vers quoi on essaie
de faire porter nos efforts depuis
plusieurs années vous avez véritablement
entamé le développement des espaces
verts dans la ville je crois qu'on a
poursuivi le développement
peut-être un accélérant la procédure ne
serait-ce que le budget alloué aux
espaces verts qui pour cette année sera
4 millions 5
or fonctionnement et personnelles
montrent l'effort que la ville morte aux
espaces verts pour traduire cet effort
sur le terrain la ville utilise les
compétences du service des jardins et
des promenades créé au début des années
1900 et qui emploie quelques 130
personnes un service compétent dans tous
les domaines de l'architecturé
paysagiste dont le travail se divise en
deux grands secteurs
c'est déjà un entretien une conservation
des grands parcs mais en même temps on
fait des projets d'aménagement nouveau à
travers la ville dans la mesure où les
espaces internet vous faites des
plantations d'armes des plantations de
fleurs également
quelques chiffres sur ces plantations
sont importantes
la production florale chez nous il ya
peu près 350 milles nous appelons tous
les ans je ne plante tt est autonome et
des plantes printanières et des plantes
bulbes s en
en ce qui concerne les pentes 5 de
nouvelles rues l'année dernière on a
planté dans les 250 art d'alignement en
pro chez cette année nous avons 350
arbres à planter annales différentes
rues de nancy
à côté des plantations au coeur de la
ville plusieurs projets de parcs ou
d'aménagement des espaces verts ont vu
le jour pour redonner de l'oxygène aux
divers quartiers défavorisés
aménagement du secteur de la chiennerie
déjà débuté aménagements prévus à
beauregard haut-du-lièvre ouverture de
nouveaux parcs comme celui de chopin de
charles iii des parcs dont on soigne
particulièrement la conception pour
qu'il se marie à l'environnement et aux
désirs de la population que nous avons
voulu celle intégrée au quartier et au
relief existence entière qui sera à
dominante végétale dans lequel nous
voulons que les gosses puissent trouver
un domaine à eux y jouer en toute
liberté en toute sécurité est laissée
aux personnes adultes aux personnages et
des coin de tranquillité et de repos
pour pouvoir se reposer et se promener
en toute quiétude
alors nous avons certaines zones dans ce
parc a s'est différenciée est notre
souhait est qu'il y n'y fasse bon vivre
à savoir qu'on est des coins particulier
originaux avec une grande décoration
minérale espaces verts et urbanisme ne
doivent plus être en concurrence même si
les problèmes restent nombreux comme le
manque de place particulièrement
ressentie à nancy bon bien faire disait
alphonse allais il faut construire les
villes à la campagne
une boutade peut-être pas si dénuée de
sens boutade dont les responsables de
l'aménagement urbain inverse aujourd'hui
les termes en faisant venir un peu plus
de campagne à la ville qui s'en
plaindrait